my name is newsworthy maker obsession
real calling investing in the region's
natural health wealth and we were
discussing about how to create the
wealth and jobs preserving the
environment and using the tools that are
available today due to the biodiversity
and the benefits are for the benefits of
the region we were discussing about what
projects are today in terms of capacity
building creating jobs for those for the
family living in the regions that are
designated for conservation there were
opinions about mining projects that are
using tools in order to renew the region
after mining and not leaving scars also
companies that
like so I have been crushes that they
sign it the agreements with farming
Association in order not to produce soya
beans in the Amazon region for example
collège de soya bean moratorium and that
is working very well in the last five
years other issues that were spoken up
related to the user technology in order
to create value and he an important
issue that was presented was the impact
of the rainforest in terms of regularity
of grain that is beneficial for
agriculture in other regions far away
and also the rivers that TN give source
of waters for the urban populations at
the end it was recommended to have a
kind of public and private partnership
exercising manners of creating
incentives or benefits for the companies
that want to invest in conservation and
using the biodiversity also we conclude
that you read reductions of emissions
from deforestation avoided that should
be voluntarily implemented even before
the annual middle of the climate
education now here finally there was a
converging see that Latin America is
among the good guys related to
environment almost fifty percent of the
forests of Latin America are preserved
while in Europe less than one percent is
preserved and that means that we have a
very important source for the olivium of
the planet